[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMAH EDOH: How is
Africa made to mean?
How has it been made to
mean, and what is associated
with this idea of Africa?
I mean, it's weird to talk
about it as this one place,
but that's exactly the point.
How is it that we've
come to talk about Africa
as a thing, a place in the
world, when in fact, it
includes over 50 countries,
and thousands of languages,
and millions of people, right?
SARAH HANSEN: Today on the
podcast, a conversation
about teaching a categorically
misunderstood concept, Africa.
Our guest today
found inspiration
for bold new ways of teaching
through her own experiences
as a student.
She recognized
throughout her education
the ability for teachers
to empower or inhibit
their students.
AMAH EDOH: What's made the
biggest difference for me
in the classroom
as a student has
been instructors
who made me feel
like I had something to offer.
And the lack of that does
a lot of damage, right?
When you're having
instructors who
make you feel like you
have nothing to offer,
that's actually damaging.
It's not just neutral.
It's damaging.
So it's really
important for me to sort
of valorize students'
voices and to show them
that they're doing it.
SARAH HANSEN: Welcome
to Chalk Radio,
a podcast about inspired
teaching at MIT.
I'm your host Sarah Hansen
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
In this episode,
I take you with me
to meet Amah Edoh, an Assistant
Professor of African Studies
at MIT.
Professor Edoh's
research centers
around the complex array of
cultures, traditions, nations,
and ideas known as Africa,
and how Africa as a concept
is produced through
material practices,
things like music, ritual,
performance, and dress.
We'll learn how she
engages students
in unpacking the
concept of Africa
through the very creative
practices that make it.
So what does it look
like to challenge
the meaning we've prescribed
to a place as rich and diverse
as Africa?
We'll pick up our conversation
with Professor Edoh's
explanation.
AMAH EDOH: You know, we're
used to speaking of Africa
as a place--
and not just any
place, but a place
that's burdened with a
lot of ideas and values
that historically have been
negative, to put it simply.
And so what my research
and my teaching centers on
is about interrogating that.
So first, making visible
the ways that Africa
is made to mean, so that's
what I mean with Africa
as a category of thought.
To understand that Africa
means more than just
this geographical space.
It's also all these
countries and all
this very complicated history.
But then to see the
ways that this valence
that "Africa,"
quote, unquote, has,
the way that that plays out in
all aspects of life, really.
So broadly speaking,
it's like the question
of thinking about Africa
as category of thought
is understanding the politics
that are involved in engaging
with the continent in
an intellectual manner,
politically, and so on.
In this course, we use creative
practices-- so the arts,
popular culture--
as a way in for two reasons.
One, because there's
a way that, you know,
I'm not crazy about the
term "popular culture"
because it's a way that
it seems to devalue it,
and it's just kind of fun.
Yet, it animates so much
of our daily experiences,
no matter who you
are and no matter
where you are in the world.
So on one hand, the purpose
or goal of using this as a way
into asking these more kind of
theoretical and philosophical
questions about Africa
as a category of thought
is to recognize that these
everyday practices are actually
extremely rich and
just as political
as any other form of engagement.
But then more
specifically to Africa
is the fact that
right now, Africa
is sort of having this moment
where its signification is
appearing to shift.
Part of it is understanding
whether it's actually shifting.
But where all the stories
we had about the continent
used to be about war,
and disease, and famine,
and dysfunction,
simply speaking,
now, there is also another
discourse where Africa's hot.
Africa is sort of the future.
Africa is where all of these new
possibilities are playing out.
So whether it's within
the business realm
or it's within the
arts, it's this idea
that Africa is
the last frontier.
So there is a way that
Africa's got a new prominence
on the global stage,
and that a lot of that
is playing out in
the realm of what
I call creative practice, so
the arts and popular culture.
And that's why I thought that
it would be a particularly
good angle to take in
addressing these sort of loftier
questions, and seeing the
ways that they play out
in the day-to-day.
And also through beautiful
and pleasant objects,
and pleasant things to engage
with, things that are moving,
and that are inspiring,
which I think
opens us up to thinking and
to processing differently when
we're moved in this other way.
SARAH HANSEN: It
makes me wonder how
this specific case of looking at
Africa as a category of thought
and looking at
creative practices,
did it open for students
new ways of seeing
the world in general?
Does this kind of teaching
offer new pathways
for critical thinking that's
applicable in many fields?
AMAH EDOH: I'd hope so.
I mean, my god, like, that's
our dream as educators, right?
That whatever we do in the
classroom in this very limited
setting or this limited scale
manifests for our students
so that they're able to take
it into their experiences way
beyond the classroom and
beyond the specific topic
of the course.
When I think about
the students that I
had in the class last year,
it was about 12 students,
and about half of them
were African, so Africans
of different variety.
So Africans from the
continent, Africans who were
first-generation Americans.
And then the other
half were American
of varying ethnicities.
And I would say that
for all of them--
well, certainly for
my African students,
it was a way that they,
I think it's safe to say
were there because they
were interested in engaging
with this part of
their experience
in a different realm,
to actually study it
in the classroom instead of it
just being kind of what they're
immersed in their
day-to-day lives
when they're back
home, and so on.
And for the non-African
students, some of them
were going to be working in
Africa during the summer,
or had just come back from
being on the continent,
and just wanted to kind
of learn more generally
about the continent.
So to what extent did
being in the class
broaden their perspectives
or kind of give them
tools that they could use
beyond this specific topic
after the class?
I think the class might have
helped them get language
to articulate some
of these questions
about power, essentially.
And if not always
to find answers,
to at least be able
to notice patterns
and sort of describe
what they're seeing.
So often, we have a feeling
that something's not right,
or that there's
something going on here,
but we don't quite have
the language for it.
And I think that that's what
a class like this aims to do
is to give students the
language to articulate
these things that they
might be picking up
on in different ways.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: So what does it
look like to empower students
to follow a feeling, to develop
the language to negotiate
that feeling into theory?
AMAH EDOH: So we met once a
week and we focused each session
on a different form of
cultural production,
or a different theme.
So we had performance.
And then within performance,
we had performance as dress,
and then we had literature,
and we had film,
and we had science
and technology.
And so for each unit,
new questions came up.
But the thread that
cut across them
was the same, which
was a question of,
how is Africa being made
to mean in the world,
and how are African
cultural producers engaging
in that process of making Africa
to mean through their practice?
And, of course,
and the questions
that come up that
are, like, what
are the specific issues that
arise with this particular form
of cultural production, right?
So for theater, what does
it mean, for instance,
to produce a play for
an audience in Nigeria
to can perform that play in
Cambridge, Massachusetts?
What are the politics of that?
What are the
questions that come up
in carrying this object from
one space into the next?
The goal was to both reflect
through each of these cases
this underlying question
that the course was after,
but then to show the nuances
or the specificities that
apply to each particular
form of creative production.
And then ultimately
to say, what do we
gain by juxtaposing
these different things?
What can we learn about ideas
of technological innovation
in or for the continent
by looking at them
alongside the production
of ethnographic portraits
in the 19th century in
South Africa, for instance?
Is there a way that
these two cases
can elucidate one another?
And I think yes.
I mean, there is a reason
that I did it that way.
But yeah, and I think that
there was also another agenda
behind it is that being at MIT
in particular, where we tend
to fetishize technology
and consider it sometimes
in the realm outside
of other material
practices, other
ways of knowing,
one of my personal missions is
to show that it's no different.
They're just different.
They're all objects.
They're all ways of doing.
They're always of
knowing, right?
So whether we're talking
about plant healing
or developing the
next nano whatever,
we can think about these
things next to each other,
no matter where
they're happening.
And so I think the ways
that case studies are
useful is that they allow
you to both kind of dig
deep with that
particular situation,
bring questions to the fore,
and then next time, kind of
consider the ways that
those questions can apply,
or when new questions
arise when you
look at a different situation.
SARAH HANSEN: You
mentioned performance.
And could you speak a
little bit about how
students attended
performances out
in the world as
part of this course?
AMAH EDOH: Yeah.
So that kind of has to
happen serendipitously.
It just so happened
to be that at the time
that I was teaching this
class, this show came, was--
I don't even remember
how I found out about it.
I think from a mailing
list or a friend told me.
I don't know, but this
play was coming to Harvard.
And similarly, that
Alain Gomis was going
to be coming to Harvard also.
And so in the case
of Alain Gomis,
I had just seen his film at a
conference a few months before,
one of his films, and
absolutely adored it,
and so I'd wanted to teach it.
And it was an amazing
opportunity to have them here,
because he would also be
speaking about the film.
And so in both cases,
it was an opportunity.
I saw these outings as an
opportunity for students
to engage with these materials
sort of in a more social way.
So it's one thing
to be in your room
and to just watch a
film on your laptop.
It's a different thing
to be in an auditorium
with various kinds of
people to kind of pick up
on the energy that's around
you, how other people around you
are responding to different
parts of the film, right?
That's part of the
experience also.
Not to mention that to
hear the filmmaker tell you
what they were thinking when
they created this thing,
and how other audiences
responded to it, and so on.
And then, of course, just the
experience of leaving MIT,
I think, is really useful.
Like, I remember when I was an
undergrad, Harvard seemed far.
[LAUGHTER]
It's really not.
And so I think part of
our duty as educators also
is to help broaden our
students' horizons,
both in the classroom, but also
by encouraging them to just
go explore a little
bit beyond campus.
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
Professor Edoh also
has a unique way
of broadening students'
horizons within the classroom
as well by reshaping
their relationship
with academic texts, all part
of an intentional process
to eradicate the barrier placed
between academic work and life.
AMAH EDOH: So when
I-- you know, I
was a student for
a very long time.
[LAUGHTER]
And I was very frequently
frustrated by the fact
that academic texts
often feel like they're
written to not be understood.
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
AMAH EDOH: And this
made me really angry,
because when I was in
grad school for my PhD,
I thought, OK, I've been
in school for many years.
How is it that this still
makes no sense, right?
Like, if it makes no
sense to me, like,
what are we doing here?
What is the point of
the academic enterprise
if we produce work that
can't be understood?
And so this has been a gripe
of mine for a very long time.
And it was all the
more frustrating
when there was no space
to express that, right?
Because I think the danger when
you're a student oftentimes,
especially at
elite institutions,
is that you internalize.
Like, when you don't
understand, you
think there's something
wrong with you, essentially.
You're not good enough.
You're not smart enough.
[BABBLING]
When it's a structural
issue, and it's actually
on the readers-- on the
writers to write better work,
write more clearly.
So then that requires, I
think, an infrastructure
to support students
in processing
this often opaque work.
And to me, that's how I was
thinking about the reading
responses.
So as a way to just when you're
forced to sit down and write
something about what you
wrote, even if it's just like,
I don't understand it.
These are all the questions
that are coming up for me.
It already pushes
you along, like,
kind of your understanding
for yourself,
and then also gives me
as the instructor a way
to know where you're at
and what I need to bring
in the classroom discussion.
So what I asked
students to do was
to try to summarize the
key points of the argument,
and then they were
free to take it
in at any number of directions.
They could either
relate it to other work
that we've read in class.
They could relate it
to stuff in the news
that they're seeing around it,
seeing around them,
and kind of use
what was coming up in
the readings as a way
to make sense of
these things they
were observing around them.
Or kind of relate it to their
personal experience, something
going on in their own lives.
And what I wanted to
do there was, again,
to show that what we do in
the classroom is not separate.
Academic work isn't
separate from life, right?
And it's not something that's
only accessible to some people,
right?
We are always theorizing.
Making sense of our experience
is about theorizing.
And so to offer
possibilities for students
to make these links between
what they're reading for school
and what they're
experiencing in the world
around them, if
we can do that, I
think we're in great
shape as educators.
I really love being able to
point to something that they've
said and make them
argue it, right?
Or in presenting my
lessons, if I can say, yeah,
as you brought up in
your paper, this thing
is going on in the reading.
That's exactly right.
And we also see-- so
to show that, one, I'm
taking their work seriously.
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
AMAH EDOH: And also, that
they have something to offer.
To me, what's made the
biggest difference for me
in the classroom
as a student has
been instructors
who made me feel
like I had something to offer.
And the lack of that does
a lot of damage, right?
When you're having
instructors who
make you feel like you
have nothing to offer,
that's actually damaging.
It's not just neutral.
It's damaging.
So it's really
important for me to sort
of valorize students'
voices and to show them
that they're doing it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: Part
of why we wanted
to profile Professor Edoh's
teaching of her Global Africa
Class was her
willingness to try things
in the classroom
that were new to her,
such as inviting
students to participate
in creative production.
This approach culminated
in a final project
assignment that, to say the
least, exceeded expectations.
In the final project
assignment, students
were asked to examine how
Africa's place in the world
is negotiated through
creative production.
What kind of challenges did
students take on in this work?
AMAH EDOH: My poor students.
I say my poor students because
this was an experiment.
I thought it'd be really cool.
I mean, it seemed like the
right thing in the course
where we're looking at people
who are making creative work,
doing creative work
in different arenas.
It seemed like the
right way to culminate
to ask students to do
the same themselves.
SARAH HANSEN: Yeah.
AMAH EDOH: And yeah, I had no
idea how it would turn out,
because I didn't know what they
were bringing to the table,
what particular skills they
had, like creative skills.
But I want to believe--
this is something I try
to enact in my own life--
that we all have
creative skills.
And so whatever you have,
we can do something with it.
And bless them, because they
were game for the experiment,
because I hadn't
done this before.
I didn't know how
it was going to go.
But I asked them to pick a topic
that they were interested in,
either something we'd
already talked about in class
that they wanted to take father,
or another topic altogether.
And the key was to use this
object, this thing that they
would make as a way to think
through these questions
about Africa's
place in the world.
It's quite broad.
But I was so happy with the
things they came up with.
It was wonderful.
It was so fun.
We had anything from, like,
there was one student who
was interested in plants.
And she picked this
plant, one of these--
I think it's like
the ficus plant.
It's some plant that's really
sexy right now in, like,
the interior decorating world.
And it's a plant that grows on
the side of the street in West
Africa, and so on.
And so she did this cool
project or she took the plant
and looked at the
different ways that it
is made to mean as a kind
of luxury decoration item,
versus in central Africa,
where it's used for--
I forget-- like, some part of
the tree's use for bark cloth.
And so from there,
you could talk
about the circulation
of objects and the way
that value gets
articulated, and so on.
Or other students who
wanted to talk about the way
that tradition--
that's kind of, yeah,
related-- the way that
tradition gets articulated.
And they were interested in
looking at wedding ceremonies
sort of in the Nigerian-American
context, where people are kind
of walking across these
different cultures, these two
different cultural realms.
And to consider what
you keep of a tradition
and what you update.
What does it mean to treat
women a particular way
and men in a particular way?
What should you uphold?
What should you
resist, given when
you are a Nigerian-American,
and you're
kind of beholden to you belong
to these different cultures?
And so what they did, which
I thought was so brilliant,
was that they put
together a picture book.
Because also, one of the classes
had talked about these photo
novels as a genre of image and
storytelling, image production
and storytelling.
And so they used that
format that we talked about
in the class and took
the theme that they
were interested in around
the politics of tradition
in Igbo weddings.
And she wrote a story
that featured them
grappling with these questions.
So it was quite meta,
because they told you--
they talked about the topic
they were interested in,
but then they also
showed you the questions
that it brought up.
It wasn't the resolved thing.
And it was meant
to be circulated,
and it was an object that could
be used to spur questions,
and so on.
And so it was fantastic.
I so enjoyed them.
We had a coffee ceremony in
class, like an Ethiopian coffee
ceremony, and the sort of
questions that brings up about,
what does it take to actually
enact what the ceremony is
supposed to enact when you
take it out of Ethiopia
and we take it into a
dorm room, for instance,
and you only have certain
implements to use?
To what extent does it retain
its value, its significance?
But it was wonderful
to see them start out
being like, oh my god, I have
no idea what I'm going to do,
and then just figuring
it out, and coming up
with something amazing.
SARAH HANSEN: We
actually have the example
of the wedding conflict
book on the OCW website.
We've linked to it
in the show notes, so
be sure to take a look.
To close our
conversation, I wanted
to see what advice Amah
has for other educators
looking to employ some of her
techniques in their classes.
What are her strategies for
keeping her class engaging,
thoughtful, and illuminating?
AMAH EDOH: So one key
thing is being clear
on what the core issue
is in the class, right?
So what's the core?
What's the question that
animates this class?
And for me, it's useful to kind
of know that and have that,
because that helps me sort
of adjust as needed, right?
So to figure out,
OK, what do I need?
What do I what do I want these
students to come away with,
no matter what?
So that if what I have planned
is not taking us there,
then I can try something
else that might get us there.
So being clear on
this question-- so
for this class, global
Africa, creative cultures,
the idea was to examine
Africa's place in the world
as being made visible
through different kinds
of creative practice.
So I structured it
according to things
that I was familiar with from
my work or interested in,
and that I wanted
to explore more.
So that's one way
to go about deciding
what the different units
are going to be, right?
So I'm interested in
dress, for instance,
and so performance as
dress was something
I was really into doing.
So the pieces of the class
can be completely different.
They can focus on different
creative practices.
You can spend more than one
week on a particular creative
practice, right?
So the building blocks
can be different.
And as long as the
core question is clear,
then you can sort of tailor
that to your interests,
but then also to
what's available.
What's cool about the
notion of creative practice
is that it's very broad.
It can be as broad
as you want it to be.
So it can be restructured
any number of ways
depending on the resources
that are available
and the questions that
you or your students
are interested in.
And tied to that
is the fact that--
someone told me, a colleague
told me once that--
we were talking.
We're both first-year
faculty, and we're both
talking about how exhausted
we were all the time.
And she said someone told her
that teaching is essentially
like stand-up or improv, right?
Like, you get up
there, and you're on.
And it's improv, because
you are responding
to what your students
are giving you,
and you have no idea
what it's going to be.
No matter how
well-planned it is,
you have no idea
where it might end up,
and you have to respond.
So it's not just that
you're there taking it,
but based on what
you're getting,
you have to figure
out where to take it
in order to come
back to conclusions
that you think you need
to end at, and also
be open to that not happening.
And when you're new,
you just don't know.
And when you've been a student,
and you've had these professors
up front who seemed to know
exactly what they're doing what
they're talking
about, you don't fully
appreciate the fact
that it's a lot
of intuitive and
improvisational work.
And so you can be surprised
at how taxing it is, you know?
So at the end of a three-hour
class, I mean, I was wasted.
You're just so tired because
it requires so much energy.
So that's something to just kind
of be aware of, which also then
can inform your preparation.
So to know, what you
need to do in order
to have enough to stock
up, to fill up your tank
so that you can then do this
three-hour improv performance.
And generally, the
less tightly designed
it is, the better
things work out.
This is what I
found and what I've
heard other colleagues say, that
the days when they were running
from meeting to meeting and they
didn't quite have enough time
to finish their course prep
were actually the days where
the class went really
well, because they
had no choice but to be there,
and listen to the students,
and meet them where
they were, and follow
that organic progression
of the conversation
instead of sticking
to their script.
Yeah.
So I think you know the key
pieces of advice I would give
are kind of one, flexibility,
both in the approach
to teaching and recognizing
the flexibility that you
have in designing the course
and choosing what you put in it.
And tied to this flexibility,
this experimental approach
to building it and to
adjusting it as it goes.
And then as a broader kind of
teaching philosophy thing, what
I said about using the
time in the classroom
as a time to build our
students' confidence,
to instill in our students
a sense that they know,
that they are capable
of doing this work,
to validate, to
affirm, and to use that
as a starting point
for what it is that we
want to impart onto them.
But really, to start to kind
of undo some of the damage
that academic work has
done for so many peoples,
which is that it's alienating.
And so to try to make it
less alienating, to say,
we can do this, and we know how
to do this, and we're learning.
And it's OK to not know, because
we're in school to learn,
right?
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
AMAH EDOH: We're not
supposed to know everything
when we come here.
To make that as
part of the mission
beyond both, beyond the
content of the class itself,
to just say, it's
OK to not know,
and to not know this
particular material.
But we know how to learn, and
that's what we're here for.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: Amah Edoh
is an assistant professor
of African Studies at MIT.
And now, you can follow her work
wherever you are in the world.
In the show notes,
we've posted a link
to her faculty page, which
includes more information
about her research background
and scholarly works.
As a bonus, we're
also giving you
a link to the Spotify playlist
that one of her students
created for the class.
It is fantastic.
Go take a listen.
Also, in our show notes,
you'll find a link
to Amah's Global Africa
Course on MIT OpenCourseWare.
For those of you who might
be new to the OCW website,
you'll find virtually all
of MIT's course content
for you to explore.
If you're an educator,
build curricula of any kind,
or are just plain curious,
please take a look.
We are dedicated
to making access
to all of MIT's course content
free and open for the world.
Visit us at ocw.mit.edu.
In this podcast, we'll be
sharing our conversations
with some of the amazing
MIT educators who've
helped populate OCW and whose
work has been shared thousands
of times from our site.
Thanks for listening,
and please stay tuned.
In the meantime, share
this episode with a friend
or leave a review on iTunes.